Bad Bosses ruin people destroy people
makes it very hard to stay above
water and so um I'm calling on bosses
all over the country to stop sucking
stop start loving the people that you
work with and by the way if you love the
people who work for you and who are
trying to help people out of the
marketplace and you love them back and
instead of saying I told but instead you
say hey man how can I serve you and get
this done we have a deadline you got to
show up and you got to go Full Tilt how
can I support you and how can I love you
in this
position you will serve more customers
and you'll make more customers happy you
will help them in their day-to-day lives
which is what business should be about
and you'll make more
money but bad leaders man if you use
your arrogance and your strength and
your position of power to beat up on
people shame on you dude